all men must die but we are not too many
[Music]
riccati
we were to show that it was a forefront
of feminism being kicked back again into
the into the ether so many fabulous
strong women
so anything we're doing all right
[Applause]
there weren't easy to carve my name is
aya stock I want you to know that the
last thing you're ever going to see is a
stark smiling down at you as you die the
North remembers we know no king but the
king in the north whose name is stark I
don't care as was a busted that starts
blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day the king in the north
we stand accused of murder
he stand accused of treason how do you
answer these charges Lord Baelish
[Music]
thank you for all your many lessons Lord
Baelish I will never forget them she
knows all the politics and she knows how
to work her way around it she's kind of
a mouse and activist getting people to
listen because at the end of the day
people still think she's just a spoiled
little girl from winter
I wish you all the happiness in the
world
Messala I'd hate to die like your son
clawing at my neck must've been horrible
for you as a Kingsguard was a father it
was horrible enough for me not at all
what I intended telepathy
I wanted to know you with me I have no
wish to kill you sir
I'm very pleased that the show has a
fantastic story which happens to have
women at the Film Fest the women are
evolved and three-dimensional still are
fascinating and as fascinating as the
men
one might say sometimes more fascinating
because we're not used to seeing women
in that kind of capacity so I'm
delighted you toured student Noah
you